- All right.
I see that attendee list growing
but we're gonna go ahead and get started
and the others continue to join.
So thank you so much for joining us
for the Decolonization
of Development Economics,
Early Voices from the
Global South discussion.
This session opens a virtual symposium
devoted to race, ethnicity,
gender and economic justice
around the world.
Hosted by Yale's Economic Growth Center
and Inclusion Economics Yale.
I'm Catherine Cheney.
I'm a reporter for Devex,
focused on technology and
innovation in global development.
I also moderate the Yale
Development Dialogues
which some of you may have seen
and I'm really thrilled to be
moderating this discussion.
So we'll be discussing how a
pioneering group of thinkers
from low and middle income countries
informed the foundation
of the field of development economics.
We're joined by panelists who will tell us
a little bit more about these economists
and the legacy that
they left on the field.
Particularly when it
comes to the recognition
of this interplay between
race, ethnicity, gender,
economic inequality
and global development.
We'll have a conversation about how,
particularly in this time of
extreme and growing inequality,
these perspectives from history
can inform the future of
development economics.
Before I introduce all of our panelists,
I'd like to introduce Rohini Pande,
Henry J. Heinz the Second
Professor of Economics
and Director of the Economic
Growth Center at Yale
and Gerald D. Jaynes,
A. Whitney Griswold Professor of Economics
and African American Studies
and Urban Studies at Yale.
They're gonna provide a bit more context
on this conversation we're having today
and how it connects to
the larger symposium.
So as I often say at the beginning
of these kinds of conversations,
why this topic, why now?
We'll start with Rohini.
- Thank you Catherine and
thank you everyone for joining.
It's, I'm very happy to welcome all of you
on behalf of the Economic Growth Center
and it's the 60th anniversary
of the Economic Growth Center
and we're delighted to be
able to host this panel.
So in the early 1950s,
as the Cold War began to gain steam
and colonization was ending,
Ford Foundation was increasingly concerned
with the idea that
poverty causes conflict.
They asked Lloyd Reynold who was then
the Economics department chair
at Yale to travel to Africa
to study the economic aspect
of this decolonization.
His daughter called this trip
a turning point in her father's life
because it inspired him to
change the focus of his work
from labor to development economics.
Interestingly his first
development economics research
was on wages and productivity
in Puerto Rican factories.
And he interviewed over
1000 workers in 85 factories
and the most striking
fact of the paper he wrote
was to note to say that
worker and foreign behavior
was remarkably similar to what he had seen
in more industrialized nations
and he directly challenged myths
that low income countries
would look very different.
After he came back he went to
the Ford Foundation for a year
where he met Simon Kuznets.
Simon Kuznets was at that
point at Johns Hopkins.
He was later a Nobel Laureate
and he often talked about the idea
that we needed a Center that would focus
on the comparative study
of national economies.
At that time there was
very little information
about these newly decolonizing economies
and so Kuznets and Reynolds together
ran a seminar at the National
Bureau of Economic Research
in 1958 which then became
the basis of a proposal
to the Ford Foundation for
Economic Growth Center.
So in December 1960,
the UN General Assembly
famously passed the 1514 UN Resolution
which was a Declaration
Granting Independence
of Colonial Countries to People
and very soon after that,
in 1961, the EconOmic
Growth Center was founded
with a 10-year Foundation grant.
It then went on to become
an endowed center later on
but when it started,
the largest organized program it had
was field study of recent economic growth
in selected countries.
The idea that Lloyd Reynolds
as the Chair put forward
was that he would hire
Assistant Professors
and in one of the earlier reports,
he described the production site.
Each of these men would
spend six to nine months
in New Haven learning language
skills and analysis skills.
They would spend up to two
years in the country chosen
and then on return they
would combine teaching
and working material.
It was certainly an
extremely important way
for the Economics department to grow.
25 assistant professors at Yale
were hired under this program.
And many of them went on to be,
to be some of the first generation
of development economists
in the U.S. universities.
Today when I look at the history
of those early years of EGC
which are very well documented
through the Ford Foundation Archives,
you know some aspects have
certainly not dated well.
I think there were a
lot of young, white men
who were being sent to
the colonies to study them
but I think in other ways,
it did identify a set of issues
that perhaps development
economics lost a bit of focus on
along the way when it
became very technocratic
which were issues of
thinking of inequality,
asking questions of what exactly
do people in these countries,
both scholars, policymakers
and others imagine as the focus.
And then I think one reason
why I'm really excited
to be doing this conference with Gerry
is that the early focus was very much
that it's a continuum of issues
that range from the U.S.
to lower income countries
when we think of issues of inequality,
when we think of issues of how do we have
process of economic
growth to work for all.
So I hope very much that this panel
can set the stage by reminding us again
of what were the discussions
in those early days?
And with that, let me
hand it over to Gerry.
- Thanks Rohini.
- Well thank you Rohini and
welcome also to everyone.
What I'd like to do is
just take a few minutes
to talk about what it is at
least that I think of as,
when I think of the phrase
decolonization of development.
And by that I simply
mean the right of nations
to self determination.
Now a right that's of course
only partly won at this point
but if we consider it and what it means
for those peoples who are involved,
I think it floats throughout
as an underlying thesis
of the entire symposium
that we'll be doing.
So to begin with, when the
Growth Center opened during 1961,
let's keep in mind over
80% of the earth's people
lived on less than a dollar a day.
Women especially were
engulfed in exploitation,
whether they were in a
wealthy or poor country
and gross illiteracy reigned globally.
The Cold War dominated
economic policymaking worldwide
and colonial powers who were
heirs to a world economy
born during a global slave trade
were reluctantly relinquishing,
at least their formal
control over people of color
across the globe.
Beneficiaries of the exploitation
were living in deep denial.
My formal introduction
to all this occurred
rather coincidentally
at the exact same time
that the Growth Center was opening up.
When Jean Soderstrom,
the white daughter of a Republican family
told my otherwise all white
ninth grade social studies class
that we were about to study for the spring
contemporary independence movements.
So I began to learn a lot more about names
like Gandhi and Nehru, Fidel Castro,
Che Guevara, Patrice
Lumumba and Kwame Nkrumah.
All leaders balancing tightropes
between Cold War powers who were vying
to control developing countries'
resources and consumers.
Now suspicious of capitalist colonizers,
the newly formed nations
tried alternative paths
of economic development.
The marginalized economist
must recognize that
the demand for self determination
without abandoning rigorous thinking.
She needs methodologies and models
that elucidate the problems of the world
but also speak to her
marginalized identity
in a profession that has unfortunately
been steeped in ways of thinking
that often underpin her marginalization.
Most adopt a premise of
post-colonial studies.
Colonial rulers are unreliable narrators
of their subjects' conditions.
Two economists whose careers
exemplified this tension,
who I met along my way in
the early days at Yale,
at the Economic Growth Center
were Carlos Diaz Alejandro,
an EGC colleague of eight years
and Sir W. Arthur Lewis
with whom I co-taught
during a year he visited
the Economic Growth Center.
I think it was 1979.
Born respectively in Cuba and Saint Lucia,
their Caribbean origins,
where slave trading and its aftermath
blended people of Asia, Africa, Europe
and New World Natives,
creating colonized peoples
who shared my status
as a member of the world's
marginalized population.
Carlos, the Cuban refugee who loved Cuba
for what it might become and not its past
shattered stereotypes
of a Cuban immigrant blindly
opposed to socialism,
real or imagined.
He supported renewing U.S. Cuban relations
even during the Cold War.
He opposed colonialist power relations
throughout Latin America and his refusal
to back U.S. imperialists' intrusion
into Nicaragua during the 1980s,
are a stark revelation of the open tension
that exists in the perspective
of a well-trained economist familiar
with both the growth potential of markets
and the human rights of peoples determined
to find their own voices.
W. Arthur Lewis, his celebrated paper,
Economic Development with
Unlimited Supplies of Labor
for which he won a Nobel Prize,
becoming the first and only person
of African descent to
do so also exemplifies
what I am calling this postcolonial turn.
His ideas of surplus labor,
disguised unemployment,
postulation of zero marginal product,
leading to contemporary models
of family utility maximization
and intra-family equity were all anathema
to the neoclassical model
his contemporaries were formulating.
Isolate the essence of his
British-style economic training
which attempts to reconcile
his rational modeling
with his gut-wrenching life experiences
in the Caribbean and elsewhere
and we see the beginnings of a atmosphere
about which his ideas
might have been formed.
If we throw in his experience in Britain
where he was engaged in
near daily ferocious debates
over politics and economic development
with the likes of CLR James of Jamaica
and Eric Williams of Trinidad Tobago
who along with other Caribbean thinkers
like Frantz Fanon of Martinique
and Aime Cesaire, also of Martinique
whose discourse on colonialism
and his notebook of a
return to my native land
along with W. E. B. Du Bois',
"Strivings of the Negro People"
might arguably be called
the foundations of the field
of postcolonial studies.
When we see all this and we
think about that training
and that experiential
existence as a member of
marginalized people of the world,
we can think that this is the surroundings
that began Lewis' framework
for discussing the reality
of economic development and policymaking
in a multi-sector complexity.
- Thank you Jerry and
you're really setting us up
for success here in terms
of something I had asked
all of our panelists to think
about which is you know,
our audience members might
have different levels
of familiarity with some of the economists
who are gonna come up
and I asked each of our panelists
to really tell us about
these people as people.
Who were they?
What impact did their ideas have?
What challenges did they face?
What legacy have they left?
And that's a great preview of Arthur Lewis
and we're gonna hear a little
bit more in just a moment.
So with that, I wanna
go ahead and introduce
three additional panelists.
Ravi Kanbur, David
Engerman and Amna Qayyum.
Ravi Kanbur is a Professor of Economics
at Cornell University.
He researches and teaches
in development economics,
public economics and economic theory
and some of his research and writing
has explored Arthur Lewis
who you'll hear about
a bit more in a moment.
David Engerman
is Leitner International
Interdisciplinary Professor
in the Department of History at Yale
and the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs
at Yale University.
And Amna Qayyum is a postdoctoral fellow
at the Jackson Institute for
Global Affairs, also at Yale.
Each of them have insights on
how some of these early founders
of development economics,
Arthur Lewis and others,
shaped our understanding of development.
And I wanna note for our audience
that I certainly have a lot
of questions for our panelists
but we want to make this as
useful for you as possible.
So please go ahead and
use the Q and A function
on the Zoom webinar to ask
your questions throughout
and I'll ask you to keep
them coming throughout,
not wait until the end so we can make this
more of a conversation and
get your perspectives in
from the get go.
Ravi, I'd love to start with you.
So as I mentioned, this was a preview
that Gerry provided on Arthur Lewis.
I wonder if you can tell
us a little bit more
about his work,
the challenges he faced including racism
as you've written about and the legacy
that he's left on the field.
- Well thank you, thank you
very much indeed Catherine
and my thanks to Rohini and
to Gerry for the invitation.
I'll pick up from where
Gerry started on Arthur Lewis
just to say that Arthur
Lewis was born in 1915
in the West Indies and he died in 1991
and then having won the
Nobel Prize in 1979.
So that sort of locates him in time.
And as Arthur, he was an
absolutely brilliant student.
As Gerry said, he's an
Won a scholarship to the
London School of Economics
and in the 1930s, he interacted
with this group of radical,
young Black radical students.
A lot of them from the West Indies.
By the way including also Paul Robeson
who at the time was at Oxford,
not at the LSE and you
know, it was that milieu,
and it led to quite a
radical stance on his part
in the 1930s and 1940s.
I think what's interesting to explore
is how Arthur Lewis over the years
became more mainstream so to speak
and moved a little bit more to the center
through his engagement
with actually the decolonization
process and so on.
And he faced quite
considerable racism in Britain.
One particular thing, you
know he was appointed to the,
equivalent position of
Assistant Professor at the LSE.
The first Black man in
history to have done so
but at the time of the appointment,
the Chair of the Department felt,
although the Chair,
the perfect right to make the
appointment felt he had to
write to the Board of Governors,
the trustees in other words
of the LSE because he said,
"We're going to be appointing
a Black man to this position."
And this is at the LSE,
the London School of Economics
which was founded by the
great Fabian socialists,
Sidney and Beatrice Webb.
So if it's in that institution
you have this going on,
then you can imagine what
was going on institutionally
and in the rest of society.
So that's just one example
of these things that he faced
and he was quite radical at
that time in his writings
and so on.
Now quite interestingly,
he had a big interaction with Ghana.
And Gerry mentioned Kwame Nkrumah.
Kwame Nkrumah was again, a
very radical leader of Ghana
who led Ghana to independence
and Ghana became independent in 1957.
And in March, and in October 1957,
Arthur Lewis arrived in Ghana
as the Chief Economic Advisor
to the new government.
And indeed the reason why
he was invited to do so,
because the radical government
of the so-called Convention People's Party
which won the election,
which swept the election,
thought that he would be bringing
very radical perspectives.
Support for industrialization,
support for state this and
that, et cetera, et cetera.
And in fact, it didn't
quite turn out that way.
Because although Arthur Lewis
was no market fundamentalist,
he was no whatever.
But he actually looked at
the situation on the ground
and he argued, actually
in an earlier report
which he had written that
in fact Ghana should focus
more on the agricultural sector,
not on industrialization.
Whereas what Nkrumah was pushing for
was a rapid industrialization,
big infrastructure projects
and so on and so forth.
And that led to a tremendous conflict
between him and Arthur Lewis
and actually the interaction
between economics and politics
is also laid out very
clearly in this thing.
In one of the letters
that Kwame Nkrumah wrote to Arthur Lewis,
after Arthur had criticized
him for the economic plan.
He said,
"The advice you have given
me, sound though it may be
"is essentially from the
economic point of view
"and I have told you on many occasions,
"I cannot always follow this advice.
"As I am a politician, I
must gamble on the future."
Nkrumah very famously said had said,
"Seek ye the political kingdom first."
And this tension between
what Arthur Lewis considered
to be rational economic advice
and the political realities on the ground
is a feature of that interaction between,
of Arthur Lewis' work in Ghana.
And he then went on
actually later on, sorry.
He went on later on actually
to write a book called,
"Politics in West Africa"
in which he talked about
this, this conflict.
Actually in my writings I've sort of,
let me just conclude with this Catherine.
In my writings I have sort
of argued that perhaps,
that perhaps Nkrumah had a point.
That in fact,
Nkrumah had to balance
tremendous cleavages in Ghana
across different ethnic groups,
across tribes and so on and so forth.
So what may have seemed
economically irrational
may have been the way that he kept
the whole show on the road.
By balancing the different
interests and so on.
And this tension between economic
and political realities in a society
with deep cleavages
and seemingly economically
rational policy prescriptions
is something, is a theme that I think
we should be focusing on
as we think about
economic policy analysis.
- Absolutely.
- So let me
stop there Catherine and I'll come back
with whatever later on.
- Thank you, no I had a
followup question for you
which perhaps I'll save
so that we can bring in
some other perspectives from history
but I wanna come back to you on it.
I just thought it was really interesting
that you mentioned how Arthur Lewis
moved from the radical to the mainstream
and I wanted to better understand
the evolution of his thinking
but maybe we can return to that.
I also really appreciate
that point you concluded on.
This tension between political realities
and what may seem like
economically rational
policy prescriptions.
So I hope in terms of finding
a narrative thread between
these different figures from history
we can understand how
economic theory bumped up
against reality and how
that shaped this evolution
of their thinking.
But thank you Ravi, that's really helpful
and we'll come back to
you with some of that.
So David, I know you've done research on
a number of development economists
who were at Cambridge
University around the same time
and their legacy.
So can you tell us a little bit more?
Maybe zoom in on a few examples
in terms of who were these
people and what legacy
have they left on the field?
- That's right, thanks Catherine
and thanks to our organizers.
I'm writing a history
of development economics
as told through the lives and
works of six practitioners.
All six were born in the early 1930s
in Britain's South Asian colonies.
They were too old to be Salman Rushdie's
Midnight's Children born
of independence in 47, 48.
We might call them instead
Midnight's Teenagers.
All six, as you say
Catherine came to Cambridge.
At that point, certainly thought of itself
as the premiere department in the world
and had a pretty good case for doing so.
All six went on to greatness at national,
regional and global scales.
One of them, Amartya Sen
won a Nobel Prize in economics.
Another, Manmohan Singh,
served a decade as
Prime Minister of India.
A third, Jagdish Bhagwati is
a perennial Nobel contender.
A fourth, Mahbub ul Haq
invented the now ubiquitous,
Human Development Index,
actually with some help from Amartya Sen
and others who I'll
talk about in a second.
And two others shaped policy
and public life in Sri Lanka.
That's Lal Jayawardena and in Bangladesh,
that's Rehman Sobhan,
who actually worked as a,
essentially a freedom fighter
for the independence
of Bangladesh in 1971.
All six of them at one point or another
worked at this exact nexus
of policy and economics
that Ravi just raised and we can come back
to that issue as well.
All of them also faced this
important dilemma which is they,
at Cambridge they learned economics
that was based almost entirely
on the economic experience
of the Atlantic world.
But they became interested
in economics initially
in order to understand the
world in which they were raised.
What was then the third
world, now the Global South.
Mahbub ul Haq has always
had a ready answer
for how to handle this dilemma.
Even in his very first week at Cambridge.
He told Amartya Sen as the
two of them were reflecting
on their very first undergraduate lecture
by the legendary Joan Robinson,
Haq said that Cambridge economists
were asking all the wrong questions.
But instead of ignoring them,
Haq told Amartya Sen
we must learn the tools
of modern economics.
"Only then" he said,
"would we be taken seriously.
"And besides," he continued,
"we can use those tools
"to pose and answer the right question."
And certainly by the record
they did ask the right questions
about the role of the state
and markets in development,
about how to build a
newly independent nation.
About the relationship
between poverty and inequality
and that actually about
the ultimate purposes of development.
What is development for?
In the work I'm doing
I'm trying to write it
as an embedded history
of development economics.
It's embedded in time and place.
Specifically in the Global South
and this kind of cuts against the idea
raised by many historians
who see development
as a Global North project
kind of acting on the Global South.
Instead this shows how development
was fundamentally actually,
a Global South project
from putting poverty eradication
at the center of the World
Bank as Mahbub ul Haq did
to the promotion of market
reforms in Sri Lanka
and India as Lal Jayawardena
and Manmohan Singh did
to the invention of human development,
all of these have a history
that's fundamentally rooted
in the Global South.
But specifically this has got
an embedded intellectual history.
One that sees the field's ideas,
not as emerging fully formed
from the minds of economists
but instead coming in response
to specific practical problems.
Kind of the friction
of theory and practice.
All of these innovations in
development theory and practice
came actually out of
efforts to solve problems.
Theory doesn't descend into the world
but actually the reverse.
Efforts to solve practical problems
drove theoretical innovation
and finally this is,
a history of development that's embedded
in networks of family and friends.
It focuses on the intellectual milieu
in which the six scholars operated.
Both in their studies at Cambridge.
It shows how the personal
connections of these scholars
shaped their work.
The contacts they made with their teachers
and each other at Cambridge and beyond.
All six of these were part of overlapping,
globe-spanning networks
that shaped their agendas.
It also touches, and
sort of being embedded
in what these economists
learned at home shall we say?
Mahbub ul Haq had two moments in the sun.
One in Pakistan in 1969
and when he announced
that even as a member
of the Pakistan Planning Commission
denounced policies that
he said countenanced
and even contributed to inequality
but really relies on a
decade's worth of work
by his wife, Khadija Haq
who had been interested
and by her own reports,
the only one interested
in economic inequality
among the Pakistani economists.
Haq's second moment in the sun,
the invention of the
Human Development Index
and the Human Development Report in 1990.
Also built on networks that
he had known for decades
including Amartya Sen but also
on the decade's worth
of work by Khadija Haq
to explore new development indicators.
Other such situations are apparent
for most of these scholars
which I could talk about
if people are interested.
I mean I think that,
it shows that these embedded histories
help uncover multiple vectors
of power and privilege
that deepen our understanding
of how development's ideas
take shape and how they're applied.
At least that's what I'm hoping to do
with this work Catherine.
- Thank you David and yeah,
I think that point is really interesting
in terms of the influence
that Mahbub ul Haq's wife,
Khadija Haq had on his work
and yet it's hard to find
much information on that
which is part of the problem
and part of the value of
the work that you're doing.
So thank you so much.
And I also thought it was fascinating
that you've mentioned the
value these perspectives,
these early development
economists bring to the field
because they want to understand the world
in which they were raised.
What I hope we can get
to in our conversation
and again perhaps a narrative thread
connecting these different
individuals is when you said
that some of these scholars were saying
the wrong questions were being asked
and they wanted to use these tools
to pose and answer the right questions.
I wanna better understand
what were those questions being asked
and what were those questions
that they wanted asked?
So hopefully we can
return to that in a moment
but I want to bring
Amna into this as well.
So Amna, I know that your work has focused
on Akhtar Hameed Khan in part
who is very relevant to the
discussion we're having today.
So can you tell us again
more about the person,
the path, the legacy.
- Thank you Catherine for the question
and thank you to the organizers
for bringing us all together
to have this conversation.
So as Catherine mentioned,
I am working on.
So my bigger project is on intersections
between global biopolitics
and postcolonial development
and one aspect of it
is thinking about how rural development
is imagined and practiced in the 1960s.
So two big points that I'd like to make
and I think this brings
some of what we've been
speaking about together.
So firstly I think
we've been talking about
the development of development economics
as it grows to a scientific
field of knowledge
but I'd also like us to think about
how it was shaped by actors
who we wouldn't traditionally
peg as economists
or even academics for that matter
and to get us thinking a little bit more
about the intersections
between developmental practice
and academic knowledge
and how those inform each
other in different ways.
And secondly, I think what I'd also like
is to start thinking about the geography
of developmental foreign practice
and David mentioned these six
economists from South Asia
who converge at Cambridge
and had these exciting trajectories
across both the Global
North and the Global South
but I'd also like to insert
geography from the Global South
as particular sites,
as crucial sites actually
of developmental thought
which put forward these models
of developmental practice.
So Akhtar Hameed Khan, just a
very brief biographical note,
he was born in 1914 in Agra
in what is present day India.
So roughly contemporaneous
to Arthur Lewis.
And he is not trained
as a social scientist
but he is rather,
in today's speak would be a technocrat
but he worked for a little while
for the Indian Civil Service
under British colonial rule
where in the early 1940s
he was posted to Bengal
and in 1943 he dramatically resigned
from the Indian Civil
Service as a sign of protest
against British colonial
policies during the Bengal famine
of 1943 and then for the next few years
he worked as a school principal in Comilla
in what is present day Bangladesh
and then in 1958 he's
appointed as a Director
for the newly formed Pakistan
Academy of Rural Development
in Comilla.
So present-day Bangladesh but
what was then east Pakistan
and what he developed
there was today known
as the Comilla model of development
and I'll speak very
briefly about the model
because there are many aspects to it
but it was based on four operators.
The formation of list of operators
and five participatory decision making
in which villages would come together
and decide on how to save and invest
for agricultural development.
There was also a focus on
labor-intensive public work
in which again, the corporate members
would work together on
projects such as irrigation,
rural works, drainage, et
cetera and a lot of these,
while they were drawing on older forms
of thinking about cooperative models,
what distinguished Comilla in the 1960s
were two primary things.
Firstly was Akhtar
Hameed Khan's insistence
on participatory and
bottom-up decision making
through mobilizing the
community and its resources.
And this was different from earlier forms
of US-led community development
that were pioneered in the 1950s
which sort of inserted
outsiders to sort of teach,
as in how to you know,
know how and how to practice various forms
of agricultural practices.
So while this was not always,
and you know, we can
speak more about this.
It wasn't always so similar to practice.
In theory what was conceptualized
was sort of two-way sharing of knowledge
and the learning process in
which peasants were leading
their community's development.
And secondly, what made
Akhtar Hameed Khan's thinking
and the project at Comilla interesting
was its focus early on,
from the early 1960s on women
and the household as what they called
not as objects of development
but as active agents of
their own development.
So while we were seeing
quite a lot of focus
in the 1960s on you know,
development of spectacle
and as Ravi mentioned,
in Ghana there was a lot of
focus on industrialization.
So the steel mill or
the dam or what have you
and this was being replicated
in a lot of other force
influential countries as well.
What the model at Comilla did
was to focus also on social norms,
gender norms and reproductive practices
as aspects of developmental
thinking and practice.
So through broad sort of
sociological knowledge
that was being produced at Comilla
and the projects that were being signed,
women were slowly incorporated
into developmental thinking
as key actors
and not just actors through you know,
whose reproduction must be controlled.
Although that was a big part of it
and I can speak more about
it if anyone's interested
but also as economic agents who required
technical and vocational training.
So I think in this way,
Comilla also provides
an early glimpse into
the ways in which women
were slowly being linked
into economic development
and thought and practice
and this would later,
forcefully I think
inform academic knowledge
in development economics as a field
and what is today known as
the women in development
approaches in the 1970s
which really came to the
fore and global consciousness
at that point.
With some ministry
economists such as Deske Jen
and Ester Boserup.
They were forcefully theorizing
the links between economic productivity,
development and gender
but I think focusing on Comilla provides
us an interesting glimpse
into not just how you know,
academic theory effects practice
but how developmental practice informs
the formation of development
economics as a field.
- Thank you Amna and I think
your question has inspired.
Or sorry, your remarks have inspired
a great question from our audience
which is also a question
that that I wanted to pose.
So you talked a lot about
Akhtar Hameed Khan's impact
on development.
Including this participatory
decision making
as well as women as agents of development.
Staying on that theme
of women for a moment
and specifically women
in development economics,
one of our attendees asks,
could the panelists shed light
on the missing mothers
of development economics?
Why do we value less the
work of Joan Robinson,
Krishna Bharadwaj and others
relative to their male counterparts.
So Joan Robinson came
up earlier and you know,
I think that's a great question
and actually one I was hoping
to pose as well as a followup.
Ravi, is that something you could tell us
a little bit more about?
- Sure I can say a few words and you know,
David said that was it the first,
first lecture that
Amartya and Mahbub went to
was Joan Robinson's lecture.
Now Joan Robinson, she was
born in 1903 and died in 1983.
So I suppose in the 50s she
would've been in her 50s
at the time.
As an undergraduate in Cambridge myself,
she was a presence up there so to speak.
But then as a young faculty
member at Cambridge,
as the equivalent of assistant
professor at Cambridge,
again she was very much a
presence in the common room,
in the faculty room.
Arguing and debating and so on.
Joan Robinson is actually known for two,
at least two things in economics.
One is her contribution to economic theory
and in particular her analysis
in the 1930s of monopoly
and in fact she coined, she
coined the word monopsony
which is where the buyer
of a product has power.
Monopoly is where the seller
of a product has power,
monopsony is where the
buyer of a product has power
and the key product for where the buyer
may have power is of course labor.
And we're seeing now with
platforms and so on so forth,
the whole question of monopsony,
the power that buyers have
of labor has come to the fore
and it was Joan Robinson
who actually did the first
rigorous analysis of
this back in the 1930s.
And there are other major
contributions she made
to economic theory at the time.
But relevant to this discussion,
she also was very much engaged
in development question,
the questions of economic
development and two things
I would point out.
In the 1970s, she became
very closely engaged
with a great Indian economist.
He wasn't at Cambridge at the time David.
He was an early generation,
he was at the LSE,
his name was K. N. Raj.
K. N. Raj who founded something called
the Centre for Development
Studies in Kerala.
And was in fact part of developing
the so-called Kerala model
of social expenditures,
attention to women's development
and so on and so forth
and it was in conjunction
with the left-led governments
which dominated Kerala for a long time,
if you like that was the economic wing
of that whole development
and Joan Robinson
had a very close
relationship with K. N. Raj
and she would visit the
Centre for Development Studies
in Thiruvananthapuram
on a very regular basis
and engage with policymakers
and so on at the time.
So that is one area.
The other area where I
think it perhaps we can have
more questions about
her is that she actually
in the 1960s engaged a lot
with developments in China
and with the cultural revolution
and North Korea and so on
and the argument is that she was,
is that she was too
uncritical of the developments
that were going on in
the cultural revolution
and also actually in North Korea
where she gave glowing
reports of developments
in North Korea.
So there's been a debate
and a discussion on that
in the literature.
Harking back to people in the 1930s
who went to the Soviet
Union and didn't see
below the surface, et cetera.
So you know, she's an
absolute giant in our field
and in my view, for her
contributions to economics,
she should've won the Nobel Prize.
Plain and simple, no question,
no question about it at all.
- So Ravi, as you mentioned
she is a giant in the field
and you know, this question
from the audience is,
why is her work perhaps valued less
than the work of some of
her male counterparts.
Or perhaps put another way,
why didn't she win the Nobel Prize?
Is this something perhaps Rohini
that you wanna comment on?
Just in terms of connecting this to
some of the broader
themes of this symposium?
- Sure, happy to do so.
Let me, you know I
recently wrote a piece on,
in fact this started off perhaps
with Cambridge School of
Economics, Alfred Marshall.
And his extreme misogyny
where he was very opposed
to women getting degrees
but also seemed to have
made very great use of his wife,
Mary Paley Marshall's great
talents as an economist.
She actually was a
coauthor on a book with him
on the economics of
industry which preceded
the famous Principles of Economics
and Marshall very
explicitly sought to keep it
out of print once his book was published.
But where I wanted to go with that is I,
and as David in fact helped me realize,
Cambridge economists wrote
very detailed letters
to each other, notes and
they're all archived.
I got email from a young
undergraduate at Yale
who had just finished last year.
She was one of the top
students of her year.
Saying oh,
I read something and I'll
read it out in a second.
Footnote 19, and this is
something I heard all the time
from my contemporaries at Yale.
So the quote was from
Marshall who described,
he put forward a set of arguments
to the Cambridge Senate on why
women shouldn't do economics
and one of them was he said,
while he felt the questions asked by women
generally relate to
the lecture or bookwork
or else to practical
problems such as poor relief,
men who have attended fewer lectures,
read fewer books and perhaps likely
to obtain less marks in examinations
are more apt to ask questions
showing mental initiative
and giving promise of
richer work in the future.
And she felt, she was always at Yale
put into the category
of the industrious girl
who came at the top of
her class but you know,
perhaps was not asking
the smartest questions.
So to link that back to what Ravi said
and why the, and many
women didn't get credit,
I think that's part of it.
So if you look to the long arc of history,
as Ravi said you know,
Joan Robinson identified monopsony.
Another person whose name came
up earlier was Beatrice Webb.
She's the person who identified the word
collective bargaining in her book
on the theory of poor critters.
Which was another book that
Marshall actively told her
not to write because he told her
she should focus on women's problems,
not on collective bargaining.
And so you know, I think
perhaps a very poignant example
of what happened to many of these women
and what continues on is actually in
a letter that Alfred Marshall's wife,
Mary Paley Marshall wrote to
Joan Robinson in the 1930s
when her book on monopsony came out.
She was also the godmother
to Joan Robinson's daughter
and she wrote,
"Thank you for helping
lift off the reproach cast
"on the economic woman."
And I think this is
something that we hear about
when it comes to race,
when it comes to gender
that the canons of economics
were often written,
not just with the notion of
someone who doesn't really exist
but also by someone who
had a very strong notion
of what work should be canonized
and I think we are still
seeing the aftermath of that.
Not just in women or economists
from the Global South
or members of certain social groups
not getting the recognition they should.
But I think even more broadly than that,
a narrowing of the
questions that we are asking
in development economics or
economics more generally.
- Absolutely, thanks Rohini
and we have some great
questions coming in.
It's actually hard to choose
which is a good position to
be in but keep them coming.
I wanna start with this question
which I thought was a great one.
In part because it's sort of looking ahead
and where do we go from here.
So this is an attendee saying,
"A lot of ideas
"on the decolonization
of development economics
"can be found in journals
produced in developing countries
"which are not given
prominence in the wider world.
"What can be done to harness these ideas
"in the field of development economics?"
So let's say there are economists
right now who you know,
50 years from now there will be a webinar
discussing their legacy but
perhaps much of their writing
is not getting the kind of attention
that it should globally.
So what can be done to change that?
Thoughts on that question?
And if not, plenty of
others are rolling in.
But go ahead Ravi.
- Well, so let me.
Let me perhaps take a
somewhat more positive
and forward-looking approach to this
and say that if we go back
to the time of Joan Robinson and so on,
there really was only Cambridge
if you see what I mean
in terms of economics.
Very little in the way
of general communication
and so on and so forth
and it was very restricted
channels of communication
and the economic journal was
a preserve of a few people
and so on.
I think what gives hope is
that situation has changed
because of new technology
and so on and so forth.
So in fact some of these,
some of the perspectives.
That one would have lost 60, 70 years ago,
at least there's a prospect
that they will be brought
to the center stage.
That's what I would, what I would say.
There's of course always the
issue in all academic things
and we have a bunch of academics here
in terms of the reification
of certain journals
and certain whatever but
that's the academic frame.
- Thanks Ravi.
Amna, did you wanna jump in?
- I think we all seem to think about
the terms of engagement in which,
well just to use the catchall phrase,
the Global South is engaging,
is being engaged with when it comes to
the field of economics and
many other academic fields
where well,
to use the shorthand, local scholars
are seen as research assistants
or information gatherers
and their insights aren't seen
as being theoretically
sound enough to actually,
they're just there for giving us
local knowledge and practice
and then it's someone who's sitting in
the Global North who will you know,
fantastically come up with
all these great ideas.
So I think maybe the smaller things
like coauthorship might
be a good way forward
in recognizing that it's,
and sort of trying to make it
a little bit less hierarchical
in terms of how knowledge
is being produced.
- Thanks Amna.
I wanna go to another great question here.
So someone asks,
"If one wants to decolonize development,
"then it cannot simply be about
a different kind of person
"engaging in development."
So we've been talking a lot
about who these thinkers were
and are and the importance of diversity.
But this person adds,
it must be about using the
tools, institutional power
and methods to create decolonization.
So the question is,
can you distinguish the thinkers
some of you have brought up
by clarifying which
ones sought development
of a single type and which ones sought
actual decolonization?
So this gets a little
bit deeper into the work,
the questions they were posing,
the work they were doing
and to what extent
decolonization of development,
not just the field of
development economics
was part of their legacy.
So maybe our panelists wanna jump in
and shed a bit more light
on the people you talked
about in that sense.
I thought it was a great question, David.
- That is a great question.
I feel like for the six
who I'm looking at there
are kind of all over the map on this one.
So two of them when,
remarkable accolades in the
Academy of the Global North
by Gwati and Sen.
I asked then where he learned
his development economics
and he said there
actually is no such thing
as development economics.
There's only economics.
And so clearly that his move
is decolonizing in some ways
and not in others.
One of the things that struck
me is how most of them,
most of the people who I'm looking at
got really deeply engaged
and devoted tremendous energy
to working in international institutions
and to creating those institutions.
So Manmohan Singh for instance
who's often thought of,
well rightly thought of as one of the,
the innovators in liberalizing
the Indian economy in 1991,
his prior job was actually working for
the socialist leader of Tanzania,
former leader of Tanzania,
Julius Nyerere in a project
called The South Commission
which was to create a thinktank
and a kind of nexus for
intellectual political life
by and for the Global South.
A number of the people I'm looking at
worked at UN agencies
at one point or another.
Mahbub ul Haq and Khadija
Haq together created
a series of smaller, more
ephemeral organizations
and so they were very active I think
and devoted extensive energy
to institution building
or working within
institutions to redirect them
and so I think that's one of
the places that we can see it
is it actually requires perhaps
leaving the academy or
at least in the cases
I'm looking at, those
who stuck in the academy
tended to be doing conventional
economics brilliantly well.
But not rethinking all of the
premises along the dimensions
that we're talking about here.
- A very interesting point
and partly because perhaps,
while remaining in the world of academia,
those theories and concepts
weren't bumping up against realities
that can change your thinking.
Other thoughts from our panelists
in response to this great question?
Otherwise we have others coming in, but.
Amna did you wanna say something on this?
- Yeah I'll just have, this is,
she delivered such a great question
and I think it requires more
thought and exploitation
but what I will say I think from,
and I think Ravi also mentioned this
is that a lot of the thinkers
that we're looking at,
they're bumping up against politics
and in many instances they're working with
a authoritarian regimes.
So in my case Akhtar Hameed
Khan is working with Ayub Khan.
Mahbub ul Haq is as David mentioned
is also an advisor in Ayub Khan's regime.
So while they're having conflicts,
I think they are more wedded to ideas
of post-colonial development
than decolonization.
If we were to think about decolonization
as a project of self determination.
Maybe someone like Rehman
Sobhan who David looks at
and who is termed as a freedom fighter
in the liberation of Bangladesh,
I think maybe if we focus on him
we can think more about decolonization.
But I think some of the
examples that we've given,
there is definitely a link between
post-colonial development,
authoritarianism
and development economics as a field.
- Thanks Amna.
As we have more questions coming in,
I wanna return to a couple
things that were said
that I think might help
build some connections
between these people who
have been brought up.
So David, that actually starts
with something you mentioned.
That some of the economists
you're focused on
who were together at
Cambridge during the same time
talked about how the wrong
questions were being asked
and they wanted to change the
nature of the conversation
and pose and answer the right questions.
So can you expand in a little more detail
on what you mean by that?
- I would just take for starters,
one of the questions they
all were engaged with
in different ways in
different times was inequality
and here we could look at this
in two different dimensions.
On a domestic level and
at an international level
and so at the domestic level,
we're talking in a moment where inequality
is seen as a perhaps
unfortunate in some cases
but always necessary
byproduct of economic growth
that would sort of solve itself.
This is the famous Kuznets curve
from Simon Kuznets who Rohini mentioned.
Whereas I think we find
in all of these scholars
a determination,
even though they had different
prescriptions shall we say,
determination to address
questions of economic inequality
at the domestic level.
Amartya Sen I think in
particular was focused
on the intersections
especially in his later work,
the intersection of economic inequality
and other structures
of domestic inequality,
caste and gender among them.
At the second level of
global economic power,
it was too easy for I think for economists
just to think of the world as made up of,
of nations with equal
rights and therefore perhaps
equal entry points into
the global economy.
Whereas I think people
like Jagdish Bhagwati,
Manmohan Singh, Lal Jayawardena
were very focused on the nuts and bolts
of global economic inequality and worked,
Bhagwati stayed mostly in academia
but Singh and Jayawardena
worked in the trenches
at the IMF actually,
at the UN Conference for
Trade and Development,
at the South Commission
to try and find ways
to address, to redress
global economic inequality.
So those, if I had one
question that would be it.
Albeit in two parts.
- Yeah that's really helpful, thank you.
I wanna bring in another
question from the audience.
Actually two questions
related to Arthur Lewis
and so perhaps Ravi or
Gerry wanna jump in this.
Here are the two questions.
The first is, in relation to the tension
between economics and politics
which has come up a few times.
Would you say that Arthur
Lewis covered aspects of this
in his book, "Theory of Economic Growth"?
That's one question.
And then the other which I'll throw in.
When teaching I would tell
students that Arthur Lewis
never claimed the marginal
product of labor was zero,
he argued that in non-capitalist sectors,
the marginal product of
a laborer could be zero
as compensated by greater effort
by the rest of the household unit.
Why was that insight
so often misunderstood?
So two questions directly pointed at our
Arthur Lewis experts here
and I wonder if you can react to those
and perhaps even shed
a little bit more light
about Arthur Lewis and
his legacy in doing so.
So Ravi or Gerry, who
wants to jump in first?
Ravi?
- Gerry, why don't you
go first, then I'll follow up?
You're muted.
- I was thinking that this
was more in your valley wick
and you should go first.
So please do.
- Yeah.
Sure, sure.
So the answer to the first question,
actually I don't think the
theory of economic growth
was directed to that sort of question
of the intricate
interaction between politics
and economics and so on.
In fact, it was our, it was
Lewis' politics in West Africa
which sort of took head on
the question of the economy.
And you know, and he was criticized
for a lot of his theorizing and that
and his analysis and that.
But it was his attempt to make sense
of what he had seen and think.
So just another little quote from Lewis.
He's talking about the
development plan in 1957 and 1958.
And this was the exchange with Nkrumah
which basically led to him
resigning as an advisor.
He says,
"It is not easy to make
a good development plan
"for 100 million pounds
if the Prime Minister
"insists on inserting 18 million
pounds of his pet schemes
"of a sort which neither
develop the country
"nor increase the comfort of the people."
Okay and that's a very sort of
technocratic economist-type
of perspective.
Of course Nkrumah's response was,
the reason why the whole
show is on the road
is because of these 18 million pounds
that I am using in this way or that way
to keep different groups happy.
And I guess we, and
certainly I as an economist
haven't resolved that
tension in my mind at all.
So that was that point
and then the second point is
a much more technical point
so I'm not sure we should
necessarily get into it
in great detail.
- It's okay.
- But it's a great point
and I actually, going back
to one of David's six,
Amartya Sen actually had
quite a well-known paper.
I believe it was in the
Journal of Political Economy
where he made precisely this,
where he formalized this
point precisely that actually,
it might look to you
as though there's
unlimited supply of labor
but actually other
members of the household
are adjusting their labor supply
to keep everything as it is.
And guess who's actually
adjusting their labor supply
when a man leaves for the city?
- Thank you Ravi.
Gerry, anything you wanna add on that
in terms of Arthur Lewis?
- Well in terms of Arthur Lewis,
the one thing I would say
is that when he was still in his 40s,
when he was dealing with
Ghana and Kwame Nkrumah,
and that one of the characteristics
of Arthur Lewis that I discovered
was that even on important questions,
he was willing, at least later in his life
to change his mind.
And I think that in some
conversations I had with him
but even more importantly,
in some formal lectures
that I heard him give,
he had mellowed a bit
from what we might call
a younger man in his 40s,
sort of hardcore, technical,
this is the economist
and these politics shouldn't
be getting in the way.
- That kind of gets back to something Ravi
was mentioning earlier
in terms of the evolution of his thinking.
So I appreciate that we
were able to go into that
in a little bit more depth.
We have some other great
questions coming in,
keep them coming.
Now some of them are
bringing up other you know,
early thinkers in development economics
who perhaps should also be
part of this conversation.
People from around the world
who've contributed to
the field and you know,
I guess it points to the importance
of having a conversation like this
because we don't talk about
these individuals enough
but again, just trying
to build a connection
between the people you all are
focused on in your research.
This is one of the questions
posed in the description
of this webinar.
We talked about what set the stage
for this pioneering group of
thinkers to define development.
And I guess I will ask that.
What, but I wanna broaden
that a little bit.
So what was the context
that allowed these thinkers
to make an impact on
the field of development
and what were some of
the very real challenges
that stood in the way of
the being able to make
the impact they could have?
So we've talked about people
who have been recognized
and received awards for really,
their contributions to the field
but also people who maybe
didn't get the recognition
they should have and
there are many other names
who aren't a part of this webinar.
So I just wonder if any of you
can talk a little bit more about,
not just the people but
the context around them.
Including issues like
racism, sexism that you know,
what were the conditions that set them up
to make a difference in the field
and what were some of the
constraints that held them back?
David?
- I would say
that the overriding precondition for it
is the partial and uneven decolonization
which provided new forms of independence,
especially the political independence
but also created reconstructed
and reconfigured forms
of economic dependence.
That admitted people
born colonial subjects
into the highest citadels
of Western learning,
in the 1950s especially in the U.S..
Excuse me, in the United
Kingdom by the 1960s,
increasingly in the United States
but also presented them with constraints
and uneven treatment.
I actually asked a number of people who,
well of these six as well as
people who studied with them
in the 1950s who were from South Asia
and almost to a person they denied
that they were treated any
differently in this time
but you also get a counter narrative.
The widow of one of them told me that
Amartya Sen and Lal Jayawardena
used to get confused all the time.
Like people would
confuse one for the other
even though they look
remarkably different.
Amartya Sen is sort of
tall, rail thin angular face
and Lal Jayawardena, completely different
and yet they were constantly confused.
Amartya Sen even told me that
he faced no discrimination.
He said, "Either for or against"
on the basis of his South Asian descent
and so this unevenness I
think is really important.
It removes some important inequalities
but left in place or even
reinforced other kinds of,
at the kind of structural level
about forms of inequality.
So I would say that the
incompleteness of decolonization.
It was a long process, it was
an incredibly uneven process
that all of these people
are entering into.
- Thanks David.
Amna, anything to add
in terms of Akhtar Hameed Khan
and the constraints, the context?
Both opportunities and constraints
in terms of his ability
to really leave a legacy?
- Yes I actually think David,
uneven decolonization is such a,
it's such a good way
to think about the fear
in the 50s and the 60s
that we're all I think sort
of collectively thinking about
because while some
hierarchies, global hierarchies
might have been reconceptualized,
new hierarchies were created.
Even within the
postcolonial nation states.
So I think, so for Akhtar Hameed Khan
I think the goals were,
geopolitical context
is extremely important.
So while older forms
of colonial knowledge,
about development were still in place
but there were these
new forms of knowledge
that were also being created.
So if we look at Pakistan as an example,
I think we can't discount the co-creation
of academic knowledge in
so many different fields
which was at many times funded by,
as even Rohini mentioned
in the introduction,
the Ford Foundation and
a particular institute
such as the Economic Growth Center.
So for Akhtar Hameed Khan,
his trajectory in the 1960s was,
he kept bumping up against Ayub
Khan's authoritarian regime
and by the sort of,
the traditional account is in 1971
he's sort of forced to flee Comilla
because of the Bangladesh
war of liberation
but since the late 1960s
you can sort of see
that the state is,
Ayub Khan's state is
getting more insistent
on putting forward more status programs
of development in Comilla
where Akhtar Hameed Khan
then regularly had
disagreements and you know,
threatens to resign, he
does resign for awhile,
then he's sort of reinstated.
So I think, but then he is also backed
by the Ford Foundation advisors.
So there is all these Cold
War geopolitical tensions
that really, and the alignments
with an authoritarian
regime that really sort of
make this project really
messy and once you know,
Bangladesh becomes independent,
then whatever the legacy of Comilla was
is then reimagined in new ways.
And it does inform in the 1980s
some of the micro development approaches
that are then pioneered in Bangladesh
but it's a story of where politics
frequently rubs up against
what the development economics
practitioners have in mind.
- Thank you Amna.
I wanna bring in another
question from the audience.
There are a few questions
around early thinkers
in development economics
from Latin America
and that might not
necessarily be the focus
in terms of our panelists' expertise.
But just questions around
these early thinkers
from Latin America
perhaps being missing from this discussion
and I think one of the
interesting points that came up
is how much of this work
was originally in Spanish
and sometimes lost in
translation to English
which is perhaps a challenge globally
when we talk about great thinking
in development economics
happening from different countries
where English is not the primary language.
So I just wanted to kind
of throw that out there.
Whether you wanna talk about
Latin America specifically
or this challenge of
language in translation.
I just think it's an
important point to bring up.
Any reactions from our panelists, David?
- I mean I agree with the
thrust of the critique,
that we're leaving out Latin America here.
I think in some parts
this is a conceptual sense
of the time that the kind of,
the action if you will,
was in newly, newly independent nations.
So the Caribbean gained independence
where Lewis and others are from.
Only in the 1960s but most
of the rest of continental
Central and South America
were already independent.
So decolonization as a name,
it sort of leaves out this.
But I think the work that Raul Prebisch
and many others, many, many others did
at the Economic Commission
for Latin America is crucial.
What's striking to me and
I've often found this puzzling
is how little the South Asian economists
connected with Latin Americans.
Either personally or engaging
in, or even just in print.
That there's this really strong disconnect
in the 50s and well into the 1960s
between these two types
of brilliant economists
in both sides
working independently on
many of the same questions.
And I think one of the
questions we might ask
is what's responsible for that,
for that barrier or missed
connection if you will?
- Yeah great point, I'm
glad you brought that up.
Ravi, did you wanna jump in?
- Yeah, just a quick,
a little nugget of an.
Just an observation.
Arthur Lewis, after he left Ghana went to,
only came back once and that was in 1963
for a conference on the seven-year plan.
Ghana's seven-year plan and
here are some of the people
who were actually
present at the discussion
of that seven-year plan.
It's Albert Hirschman, Nicholas Kaldor,
Osvaldo Sunkel and K. N. Raj.
The person I mentioned earlier
as being very, very important.
So you know, the point is I think,
the occasions for these
people to meet and discuss
were few and far between.
Because we did this in the 1960s and so on
and travel and so on and so forth
and the creation of these UN,
the Economic Commission
for Asia and the Far East
which was ECAFE at the time,
it's now ESCAP, Economic
and Social Commission
for Asia and the Pacific
and then ECLAC in Latin
America, et cetera.
In some sense, I suppose segmented
the discourse in that way
and it's not difficult to
imagine that it was difficult
for actual get togethers in that time.
But here's one small example
where they all came to assess Ghana's,
and Ghana's plan from Latin
America, from India and so on.
- Very interesting and kind of echoing
your point earlier,
when there was this question
about academic journals.
At least a point of
optimism is sharing work
across geographies is easier today
than it was at that time.
For scholars to be able to
come together despite distance.
I wanna get to this great
question from the audience
and it points to something
that I was hoping
to get to in our conversation.
One of the things I
wanted to really make sure
we talk about is, you know,
how are these figures
that we've talked about,
from history,
continuing to inform
development research, policy
and practice
and some of you alluded
to that in your remarks.
But here's a specific question
on their legacy today.
So this comes from the audience.
Thinking about the turn
towards poverty reduction
and away from an earlier era of focus
on addressing global inequality,
how did these economists
relate to this turn?
What role did they play in it?
David?
- I can start with it.
I mean at an institutional level,
the World Bank, then
the and I suppose now,
probably still the
largest single institution
in the development landscape.
Their turn toward poverty eradication
came primarily through the
efforts of Mahbub ul Haq
who convinced a dynamic,
new World Bank President,
perhaps doing penance for
his leaving the Vietnam War
for the 1960s, Robert McNamara to push,
to change the focus at
an institutional level
of the world towards poverty reduction.
But I then, I also think that
sticking with Haq for a second
the focus on human development
helps us really understand
the rise of NGOs on the one hand
which were well-equipped
to handle questions
like health and education
which were kind of factored
into human development
beyond just national income.
And so we can see in this,
I wouldn't say that Haq
predicted or made this happen
but it was consonant with a move away from
big national institutions,
toward international NGOs and even local,
regional and local NGOs.
Taking on smaller scale,
taking on smaller scale projects
rather than just advising
national governments
on their national plan.
- Really interesting, that's
a world I cover closely
and honestly I was not as
familiar with his influence
on the development of,
really the whole NGO sector.
So really interesting.
Other thoughts in terms of
more broadly how you know,
these figures that we focused on today
continue to affect development economics,
development policy and this
turn away from addressing
global inequality towards
poverty reduction.
Which perhaps some might
argue may turn again
toward addressing global inequality
given some of the issues we're seeing.
Gerry, did you wanna jump in on that?
- Yeah but just a short, small point.
Let's not forget that reducing poverty
is reducing global inequality and in fact,
if one were thinking about
what is the quickest way
in the short run that
I could try to reduce
global inequality would be
to try to reduce poverty.
One way of thinking about this is that,
'cause there was also an earlier question
about the rain is fay,
more a formalization of Lewis' model
which ignored various issues
having to do with inequality
and things like that.
One way of thinking about that
is those are models and ways of thinking
that are looking at policies and issues
and their long run effects.
As opposed to thinking
about the short term effects
of policies and trying to do
something in the short term.
And I think that this turn
that's being talked about
towards poverty reduction
which is kind of getting
at the more micro level
of where individual people are
or individual communities
are are in effect,
thinking about I wanna do
something about poverty
in the next five years or I
wanna change global inequality
even though it may not be some huge change
in the short run.
So I think we have to put those questions
into some kind of perspective.
- Thanks Gerry, other thoughts on this?
Otherwise a couple more
questions rolling in, Ravi.
- Yeah I suppose just
reacting a little bit
to Gerry's point.
I suppose the concern might be that the,
what if the causality runs
from global inequality
to poverty in individual countries.
I suppose that's the nature of the things.
So I suppose in an accounting sense
if I reduce poverty in a country,
than almost by definition,
global inequality as measured will reduce.
But does the global
inequality in some sense,
does it have the seeds of
the structural processes
which lead to poverty in these countries.
Now that will be,
now you know Arthur Lewis again,
going back to Arthur Lewis,
he had some, his surplus labor theory
actually also helped
him understand he says,
global inequalities.
So he has this phrase where he says,
"When I look at plantations," he says.
"There's been tremendous
technical progress
"in efficiency gains in the
production of plantation crops
"over the last 100 years."
Or whatever.
"And yet," he said, I remember the phrase.
He says, "Plantation workers
are bare feet and wear rags."
Something like that he said.
A question is why.
It's because their wages are held down
by this unlimited supply
of labor that's coming in
from the countryside.
So all the gains of technical progress
are actually going to the
owners of the plantation,
not to the workers.
It's when that surplus
labor ends, phase ends
and wages start rising,
labor markets tighten,
that's when you start
to get the effect on,
good effects on inequality
of the technical change.
And of course, if one looks
at China's development
just now to bring it to
a contemporary frame,
that is one, that would be one argument
as to why it is that
inequality rose so sharply
in the Chinese context.
Because there's this massive
supply of so to speak,
surplus labor coming in from rural areas.
Essentially holding wages lower
than they otherwise would have been
and it was only really when
the so-called Lewis
turning point was reached,
when the labor markets started
tightening in rural areas,
that wages started rising in rural areas,
that maybe some positive effects
on the reduction of inequality
started coming through.
So that if you like,
is a translation of the Lewisian
perspective from the 1950s
to the current Chinese discourse.
Some of us have been arguing
that maybe Chinese inequality,
at least is not increasing
at the rate that it was
and one of the arguments is that,
that the Lewis turning point
so to speak has been reached.
- So I wanna give enough time and space
to throw out one final question
and given the complexity
of what we're discussing,
I wanna make sure that
each of our speakers
have really a couple minutes
for any final thoughts.
But first I wanna bring in
what's a comment from the audience
that I think is highly relevant.
The comment is,
it would be great if the
idea of decolonization
transcended the list of early greats
in development economics
to encompass the new
understandings of the term
that have emerged among people working
in the Global South today.
So I think really that comment
is connecting this
conversation we're having
in the opening session,
talking about these early thinkers
who influenced the field
of development economics
to the themes of this symposium
that will continue Friday October 29th
as well as Friday November 5th.
So again the point is,
how do we talk not only
about these early greats
and the legacy they left,
but new understandings of the term
of the decolonization of
development economics?
Especially for people working
in low and middle income countries today
and so to turn that into
the form of a question
and really give each of
you a little bit of time
to connect the people you talked about
with the themes of this symposium.
Do you have any final
thoughts on the importance
of considering these early voices.
As we gear up for the
symposium focused on race,
ethnicity, gender, economic
justice and global development.
And we'll start with David, Ravi and Amna
and then I'd love to close
with Rohini and Gerry
and help connect this opening session
to the larger symposium.
David, can we start with you?
- I was afraid you were
gonna say that Catherine.
It's a really big question.
- It is.
- I'm not exactly sure,
exactly sure how to take it.
I mean I do think that
that question of inequality
that was so important to these figures
really remains a central
question, a question today.
And it was there, that
was the right question
that they were asking.
I might actually add to it
something that's come a little bit,
I guess a weak theme,
particularly in some of Ravi's comments
which is a kind of temporal inequality.
One of the things that those scholars
I'm writing about were focused on
was consumption now versus
consumption later right?
And the idea would be
that some sacrifices now
will provides goods later.
Joan Robinson perhaps typically
had a great sentence about
that when she visited Sri Lanka
in the late 1950s and saw
this robust welfare state,
social welfare state.
That she said that,
"Sri Lanka was eating the
fruit before growing the tree."
That it was spending rather than saving
for the short term and so
I think one of the issues
that we see people like
Amartya Sen deal with
in academics and formal language
and we see others like
Mahbub ul Haq deal with
in a kind of more political vein is
this other dimension of inequality
which is how do you balance
the current against the future?
And it's plausible to think
that with our current
interest in global inequality,
certainly since 2008, even
just in economic terms,
that that becomes central.
I would say that this group,
for all of their insights,
the ones that I'm looking at,
were not necessarily the
right ones to look at
the interface of the structures
of economic inequality
with other structures of inequality.
And it's too kind of a vexing question
to answer directly right now
but I would say that
when you ask economists
to talk about inequality
it's not a surprise
that they turn to economic inequality.
- Yeah.
- And so perhaps
the message is one of Amna's,
about bringing in people
working on boundary,
on the boundaries or
economics and its neighbors
as a way to continue this
process moving forward.
- Thanks David.
Amna, can I bring you in next?
- Sure, actually David
that's a great segue for me.
So one of the things I was
gonna say is that what was,
I mean the Comilla model obviously has
its critiques and problems
but the one thing that it was doing well
is that it was interdisciplinary
in nature right?
So it wasn't just economists
who were producing knowledge
but it was also
anthropologists, sociologists
and political scientists
who were there and really,
they were living in Comilla,
they were going out into the communities
and working with people
and producing these forms of knowledge.
So I think maybe focusing
a little bit more
and taking more seriously
local knowledges and practices
and then also broadening our visions
of what the political economy is.
To really bring reproductive practices,
to bring the family into focus
when we think about political economy
and it's not just about you know,
rational economic agents.
I think that might be sort of ways of,
you know, some things we
should be thinking about
as we move forward with economic lessons
and maybe one last point.
Thinking again about a lot of these,
about my projects
and where the funding is coming from.
Is to think more seriously about sort of,
who, what are the power
structures in place?
And who gets to benefit
the most from these forms
of expertise and funding?
So just being more sensitive
to funding source as well.
- Great point, thanks Amna.
Ravi.
- Yeah so let me just say,
I mean I agree with all the
things that have been said
on this thing and just
speaking as an economist,
as an economist.
You know economics has a lot of strengths
but also a lot of weaknesses
and I say that perhaps
the greatest weakness
is that economists don't
know the weakness of their,
the weaknesses of their discipline.
They focus a lot on; strengths
and there are a lot of strengths.
No question about it.
So I would say that for example,
that we don't engage with history.
We don't engage with the
history of our own disciple
let alone history more generally
and that's what we've been saying.
That there are real insights to be had
by going back and seeing
what these greats,
how they interacted with
the world and so on.
And the second thing
that we tend not to do
is to interact with other
disciplines too much.
And I think what this discussion has,
what Amna was saying and others.
Really that that engagement
I think is not only leads to
good policymaking and so on,
but it also actually
leads to good economics
and defined in its own terms.
So let me leave it at that.
- Agreed and that's part
of why I'm so grateful
that Rohini and Gerry
have brought us together
because it's addressing
some of those problems
you just articulated.
This discipline not engaging
with its own history enough
and not engaging enough
with other disciplines
and I think this,
this opening session of this symposium
and the whole symposium
will be really valuable
from that perspective.
So Rohini, Jerry.
You've kind of kicked us off
in terms of why this conversation, why now
and we'd love just any final
reflections from the two of you
and maybe connecting this conversation
that we're having today
to the larger symposium.
Gerry, you wanna start?
- Okay, well just very briefly,
I think that the last
comments that were made
kind of would take us back to
I think David was talking
about someone among his six
who mentioned that at Cambridge,
the economists back in the 40s or 50s
weren't asking the right questions.
Well at least they weren't
asking all the right questions.
And that's where I think
the rest of the symposium
is going to be trying to go.
We've tried to bring together people
who are asking questions that,
that are somewhat different
from what we're usually going
to see in economics journals
and part of the reason
for that I would say,
which connects to David's point
and the one that Ravi
just made as well as Amna
is that one gets rewards
in the economics profession
by publishing in certain kinds of journals
and you'd publish in
certain kind of journals by,
on the basis of
methodological sophistication.
So when you start asking why
aren't economists interfacing
with economic history
and with anthropologists
or political scientists more,
that kind of is already your answer.
You, you're gonna be posing
questions that are broader
than the ones that can
just solely be answered
with the kinds of methodological tools
that are going to get you
published in these journals.
So we're kind of interested in asking
some of these broader questions
and asking how might we,
what methodological means
can we use to approach those questions?
So I hope that the people
who were here with us today
can continue with us to
get some of those answers.
- Thank you Gerry.
Rohini, we'll go to you.
- Thanks, I don't think
I have much to add.
The one last point I'd probably add
and maybe this goes back
to the discussion of
where did the inequality
discussion go in development
is that we are also hoping to,
in a lot of ways not silo development.
I mean development was a very
old product as a discipline,
it was a very old product.
It was defined by, at
the end of colonialism
and most fields in economics
are not defined by country.
They are defined by for instance,
if you're thinking about labor economics,
you're thinking about
issues in public economics.
And today, the field of
development in some ways
is perhaps killed by its
own success in that it,
if you're talking about issues of say,
affirmative action and inequality,
those conversations should be happening
across people thinking
about them in the U.S.,
in Malaysia, in India
and yet sometimes that gets very siloed.
Issues of inequality need to be dealt
by thinking about tax
systems and public finance
but that's, if you look at
the public finance literature,
that's usually a very U.S.
focused literature in economics.
So I think one thing that I
would love to see come out
over the next few years as we
broaden these conversations
is really to say that when
we ask these questions,
we shouldn't really think about it,
"Oh it's a development
"because it's talking about Nigeria
"and it's not development
because it's talking about
"the US or UK."
But rather think about
what the question is
and I hope that this conference
gets us started on that.
- Thanks Rohini, great points.
So that concludes this opening
session of the symposium
and again, this is just the beginning
of a virtual symposium devoted to race,
ethnicity, gender and economic
justice around the world.
Hosted by Yale's Economic Growth Center
and Inclusion Economics Yale.
It will continue on Friday October 29th
and Friday November 5th
with researchers presenting
on the costs of
discrimination based on race,
ethnicity and gender and
paths to economic justice.
You can see information
on registration here
in Zoom if you're joining us live.
We really appreciate all
of you in the audience
for taking the time to tune in.
Thanks for your great questions.
Look forward to continuing
the conversation
during the symposium and
thanks again to our panelists.